hello and welcome to this video
a new game three plus two i have lost
three uh
games in a row in three zero and this
seems to be too
no no
i wanted to play e4 now he gets a very
reasonable
pun off here anyway um
i tried three zero as a practice
format for my uh other
games on the server but it just it seems
to be too fast
to uh i mean too fast to still provide
some meaningful commentary
why don't what is going on here
i mean i know that i screwed up the move
order but this is already pretty awful
it was more of a mouse slip almost e3
anyway you shouldn't have such a bad
position
yeah i'm more or less losing the d pawn
it's a
little bit strange d5
knight e5 is just too awful
very strange
i don't
did know miss maybe i should have played
h3 early on
i will i will show you earlier um or i
will show you after the game
my move order screw up
so that you better understand what i'm
talking about um
okay i have to clarify this i know we
can take take on d4
i just have to try to find compensation
in this in this position
and i have a little bit it's not like
there's absolutely nothing
the development is fairly good he cannot
move the rook
this one i then knight d4 is an issue
that's a pain okay i have to take then
not what i wanted
this one knight d4 queen f4 is
not so good
for him and here there's
knight b5 queen b8
can we get something going in this line
probably not so maybe this one
trying to at least damage his pawn
structure on c6
it's not an easy
job to win if i get to take on c6 and a
double the pawns
he's still struggling a little bit like
with on f7
rook cannot move so i'm going to
take here the bishop is is a good piece
of course but
getting his pawn structure damage is
worth something
okay just well b3 looks
normal i can also check him though
yeah let's check him
king g8 looks completely normal
or is he going for f6
f6 okay
it's a useful tempo
okay so he wants to go e5 in the
nearest future but let's go b4 first and
make sure the c pawn is not moving
now that's not easy at all for black to
convert okay
[Music]
just have a look at the pawn
and maybe i can go a4 b5
so cover that make the queen more mobile
now i can actually go to the d file and
threaten rook d6
you should play queen to b5 that makes a
lot of sense
and now um
queen two h4 maybe for a tempo
yeah attack the pawn this is three plus
two so
it's not
like you have to panic or something with
them with the minute on the clock
take this pawn
it's fairly difficult i think for black
to convert
now what what am i doing here rook d8
he's got a check here
and it's got c5 lined up
okay
yeah this is also not terrible the rook
ending
c5 this rook c4
um
i have actually overlooked that after c5
is also threatening c4
that is not so great
okay
a little bit surprised by this approach
i'm not sure if it's bad it's just like
i didn't expect this to this this way of
playing
[Music]
i mean i have two a pawns
and it's clear that the second a pawn
here is not so
useful but still
get the king closer okay
[Music]
someone wants to go there okay a6
i'm not going to promote the a pawn that
sets clear
i just want to i get to want to get the
king active but he's got rook d2
then this is a bit of a pain
okay
make a fast decision
the e-pawn okay
as this is blocked fairly
safely now
[Music]
ch
that's good for black really
you have to take two two a pawns
yeah sorry i'm not going to uh take the
rematch which is always a little bit
questionable and
i know i'd like to take it but i also
like to make a big
quick analysis now i i i slipped e3
i want to play e4 in this position and
then go to maroxybind
the movie 3 is not so
well pointed here because there is no
knight on c6
this is a difference like if we compare
this
for example if black
let's go okay after we go all the way
back
i want to make this comparison like here
if you play e3 you actually
threaten to play d4 d4d5 kick the knight
away
and in this situation here
this is a different thing because here's
the knight here's the bishop
here i can play queen to b3 and initiate
this interesting sequence in the actual
game
we had this with bishop here instead of
knight c6
queen b3 here he can simply take and now
that move makes no sense he can he can
just secure
the knight yeah this is a big problem he
has king of eight the bishop is already
here so
this is just a lot worse in comparison i
still should not be
yeah better worse i'm sorry
i have to react here probably a h3 or
something
so that i'm actually safe from losing
the pawn immediately
the position is already as you can see
from the engine eval is already fine for
black
but in the game it was even more
annoying
only here i realized the problem
and there are various ways for black to
be fine
taking this was actually wrong because
rook fd1 was strong okay
yeah you know i made one mistake i mean
more than one but um
okay this is good
threatening this actually
yeah what exactly is black's move i'm
threatening bishop h6
what i didn't see actually i thought i
could go rook fd1 here but he has knight
d4
this is just a move attacking the queen
and now
attacking the bishop and okay this still
seems to be compensation but yeah
it's maybe better than bishop g7 but
my original plan didn't work so i had to
kind of try to find
a compensation here and
it seems that queen e5 now was strong
simply
refusing to take yeah after he
took it um i think this this is giving
reasonable chances to draw really
yeah here i'm totally out of the woods
rook d6 uh that was not really difficult
to see
or queen d2 already with a better
position
maybe i was not um ambitious enough
in particular rook d6 is not rocket
science it's just a double attack
and i mean he has the pawn but
everything else
is bad he's weakened all over the place
c6 e6 the king so rook d6
yeah i just win a pawn there for
material equality
and this is just like i'm just playing
for
[Music]
compensation let's say and maybe missing
small things possible
um yeah i wonder if the end game was
lost at some point
i was surprised at his a5 move but it
seemed okay
i thought you would just go c5 that was
my take
this and yeah either take or go here
that was what i was thinking but a5 is
an interesting move
so black is definitely
fine i mean he's he's probably
maybe he had more than
equality later it's very much possible
so here
yeah i think it should be okay for me my
king is playing
the pawns are something that he has to
attend to
rook a7 maybe but the likelihood that
we get some kind of drawn ending here is
very high
e4 is probably not helping but
this like rook h8 rook e8 let's say
luke takes rook takes rook takes
g4 or something it's
very likely should be a draw even though
black is
black is better but it should be
holdable
i think in a blitz game okay we don't
know what happens but
yeah this is um probably not the way to
go
and rook c7 is just blundering just a
blunder
i think it's just a draw i mean he can
draw in every
every way probably like this or so
yeah but that dead wins a5 was also
quite good
um but okay the the king and pawn ending
is winning so
yeah now he's just far too slow
pick this up and i'm just
like miles away it did this is a case
where having two a
pawns is good yeah it takes time to
actually capture them
okay guys thanks for watching
kind of i just see that
the top text is not there that no there
is an uh an area missing with the
opponent's
name and rating that's odd
weird anyway i have to fix that
thanks for watching